hi I'm Joy Taylor host of speak on FS1
and you can check me out on the bootleg
Kev podcast
special guest here you might see her on
TV every day if you watch FS1 Joy Taylor
welcome thank you for having me of
course you're super dope I've been I've
never watched you on TV for so long like
I was like like uh I was just talking to
my boy because we're big sports fans and
I told him you were coming on the show
he's like yo Joy is fire I give um yeah
you've been a staple on television for
you said it's been six years I've been
at Fox for seven years okay so let's get
six and a half years because we launched
Undisputed about six and a half years
ago okay six and a half years in
September so you were born in Pittsburgh
yes but do you claim Miami so this is
how it breaks down I was born and raised
in Pittsburgh right so I lived there
until I was 18. still was on a family
there like you know it's 4-1-2 forever
obviously right but I went to school in
Miami so I I kind of say I was like born
and raised in Pittsburgh and then like
became a woman in Miami right and then
obviously now I'm in L.A and I've been
in La for seven years so la is like home
now too and then your brother's like a
dolphins Legend So yeah so Jason well I
had like gotten introduced to Miami
obviously through my brother and like
growing up in Pittsburgh you're not just
like randomly hopping down to Miami
um but yeah like that's how I became
aware with the of the the area right and
what made me want to end up going to
school down there so yeah he played for
Miami for 13 years legend in the NFL 15
years in first ballot Hall of Famer
first ballot
um you did you end up starting like your
broadcast I think I saw you started your
broadcast career in Miami at a station
out there yeah so I I started in radio
um me too I'm still on the radio every
day yeah I love radio I started in radio
in 2007.
[Music]
um I started in radio 105 so yeah we're
the same age I just yeah I saw you were
born in 87. I've been I'm same same age
yeah 80s babies
um yeah so I wanted to start on radio so
you will know this also you know shows
and podcasts and YouTube shows and
digital shows did not exist of course
you know I was in college when we were
coming up in the business if you wanted
to be a personality
really radio was the way to go
especially if you wanted to talk and
with sports it was just around that time
that the you know first takes and Colin
show and all you know those PTI were
really starting to take off and the
direction of the business was changing
to more opinion shows than it was just a
traditional Sports Center recap shows
that's because of phones we were had
more access to Highlights so we could
see all that if if we wanted to on
Facebook or Twitter right we don't we
don't have to wait for it for
SportsCenter which you used to have to
do so it shifted the business so I
wanted to be able to talk I wasn't
really interested in being a reporter or
a beat writer and radio was a space to
get into to give you that opportunity so
I started in sports radio at 560 QAM in
Miami that was my first internship wow
interning is in radio for people who
don't know at least back then I'm sure
it's rough because did you you probably
didn't get paid anything no because back
then I got paid nothing no like you're
just you should just be happy to be yeah
that it was it was being paid and happy
to be here no I mean I did I did it for
school credits obviously right that's
that's the caveat you get yeah I I
actually was not going to college but I
had to go to college to work at the
radio station so my college career
only exists because I had to go to
college to get credit to work at the
radio station yeah I feel like we've
evolved
past all of that now yes and and the
media world has expanded so much that
that doesn't really exist but at the
time it was just really traditional
media forms writing you know newspapers
radio television were you setting up
tents and stuff oh yeah yeah yeah I mean
you got to do the promo stuff you gotta
hand out yeah at the table Yeah I go to
the promo events
um you know get coffee do the rundowns
whatever but I actually got great
experience interning not all internships
are are great and it's the world of
interning has completely changed since
we were in returning obviously but I
also got the intern for DJ Laz who was
on power9 Legends
so my first internship was with Joe Rose
at 560qam and that was a sports Morning
Show and then I was able to get an
internship through constantly poking my
head in bothering classes that was when
he was doing mornings at Power 96 yes so
so I got an internship there and works
past my school internship and you know
just did the internship for free
whatever but I got incredible experience
and I really learned how to produce
shows from working with Laz because
sports and entertainment crossover so
much for sure and we would obviously
talk about the local teams but obviously
we're doing a Morning Show as well so
you gotta you know see what the internet
is talking about you know what's going
on locally is there something in town
we'd always have music guests and you
know actors all kinds of different they
always say Like Rappers want to be
athletes and athletes want to be rappers
well yeah I mean there's a lot of
crossover in the culture and especially
in Miami yeah I mean really everywhere
it's there's just a lot of crossover
with culture and sports right and um
it's it's really throughout all of
society though it's not even really it's
just with music sports are such a big
part of our existence and I think we
really got a whole acknowledgment of
that when we lost sports during the
pandemic
I was gambling on South Korean baseball
yeah it was bad who was it we needed
something live on TV it really for me it
will always make me appreciate just
being able to turn a game on during the
regular season that we might be like oh
it doesn't really matter just having
that sense of normalcy taken away from
you yeah was really jarring so but
sports are just a big part of our Lives
what was it like for you because you
guys were still doing TV right yeah so
that I mean because there's like down
times in the sports calendar where
there's I want to say there's like a
patch that we're about to approach we
are very close to over a few weeks NBA
ends and then all you got is baseball
yeah which I'm not the hugest baseball
fan I don't know where you are on
baseball but I'm not very passionate
about baseball but it's like the dark
times it's like waiting for NFL hope
like okay what kind of nerdy [__] is
going on in the NFL that we could hear
about but
um I can only imagine during the
pandemic there's like nothing like I
would be listening to like Bill Simmons
and [__] and they would just be talking
about uh the Michael Jordan documentary
yeah it saved us so Colin and I joke
about it all the time because we didn't
really take any time off
and we did our Regular Show which is
five days a week three hours a day
every day during the pandemics no live
sports yeah so luckily
for the timing of the shutdown for our
show matched up with the end of the NFL
season so the NFL season had gotten in
we got through the Super Bowl right and
it was Matt it was you know NFL off
season so even though the NBA shut down
we still had a lot of content going on
with NFL offseason because the NFL just
moves forward with the idea that like
we're gonna get through this and play
the the I think in that off season
DeAndre Hopkins got traded to my
Cardinals for scrapped Tom Brady moved
Tom Brady there was a lot of Aaron
Rodgers stuff uh there was a bunch of
Cam Newton news so we just kind of I
mean we repeated a lot of topics but we
once we got to the dock that's really
when we were like we need something to
talk about let's talk about this Netflix
series right like it's like it's like
it's live we also watched it like that
like everyone was so Dying For Sports
content that we really and there were
some reveals in it for sure but for them
we were watching it like oh my God
what's gonna happen
when we really watched it like it was
live but it was a great experience in
that sense like there were some things
that really kind of all brought us
together as sports fans and that
documentary I mean I'd say this it gave
us content so yeah um you okay being a
part of Skip Bayless he leaves ESPN
obviously him and uh Stephen A Smith
have this legendary show for all these
years
somehow the magic gets recreated but in
my opinion much better I think him and
Shannon are I just love them together
more than I love the Stephen a thing but
you're there on day one
because that that's a big I remember how
big of a deal it was that skip left and
it was just like oh there's something
going on here and you're kind of you're
there so like what was it like early uh
early when it comes to just seeing those
two form their chemistry and just that
whole entire time in sports media it was
a real
experience especially to be the part of
like you said a big story and launch
it's always cool to launch a show but
when you're launching a show with a Hall
of Famer and Shannon sharp and Skip
Bayless like the Skip Bayless and
everyone's watching to see what the
chemistry is going to be like and how's
it going to look right you know is it
gonna work are they gonna get ratings
and it was it was really a wild thing to
be a part of we shot a bunch of
commercials or all these promo shoots
and there's these Billboards and you
know stories going on and it was also
the first time that we had done a show
together so that part of it also like
behind the scenes getting into the Beats
of a show as
as structured as a debate show in that
format is is a whole other challenge to
do because as you know it gets heated on
that show it does and you have to be
able to balance what we're talking about
is just about this and not personal and
then you have to move the show along and
you're kind of like an adult in the room
kinda well I'm moving everything so like
we got to get the commercial break like
when do I jump in to cut him off so that
he feels like he's had everything he had
to say so there's a lot of moving Parts
but it was it was an amazing experience
we traveled a lot we went to McGregor
fight in New York we were at the
McGregor Mayweather fight we were at the
US Open we were at the NBA finals in
Cleveland the NBA finals in Oakland the
Super Bowl so it was a really incredible
incredible launch and it was a great
experience working with both of them and
I mean we had a we had a lot of fun on
that show is do you think Skip gets a
bad rep sometimes because he genuinely
Timmy comes off like a nice guy like
he's I just think that you know he's so
dug in on some of his I mean he's
opinion is right so I I don't ever tell
people how to how they should feel about
anyone I I know what my experiences are
with them Skip's always been extremely
generous with me a great mentor he's
given me some some great advice over the
years he's gives strong opinions and
sometimes most of the time people are
going to disagree with your opinion
right that's what the opinion space is
so I don't really find that it's
particularly unique to just skip because
I've worked with Skip and I've worked
with Shannon and I've worked with Colin
and I work with other opinionists now
and I worked with big Personalities in
Miami
that's what you're doing if you're
giving your opinion the reality is most
people aren't gonna like what you have
to say I mean I deal with it now I get
my opinion every day I know people
aren't going to like what I have to say
sometimes right and that's fine because
that's what my opinion is now I think my
delivery is maybe a little cheekier than
skips but you know that's that's his
style and he's he's okay with people
disagreeing with him were you there the
first time Shannon pulls out a goat mask
on TV
um I think it was yes yes because he we
actually ended up bringing in an actual
goat into Studio one time so it had to
have been after the goat mask
because he because he was wearing the
Jersey the first time because he's so
funny he's worn it so many times I've
lost track but I think the first time he
had a jersey on yeah and and and and
then he had the goat master and then the
goat mask yes and then yes and then he
because we brought an actual goat into
the studio like a real actual goat so
that had to have been after it I just
love like how he'll bring weed on the
set and he'll be like skip this ass
I was like this is this is amazing like
like if you would have told me like 10
years ago that [__] was maybe bringing
some uh some tree on the side some tree
and cognac on live TV it's just we have
a lot of abilities who really dig into
our personalities over there which is
fun like you can really you can really
be yourself and that's that's what
people relate to is when you are
enjoying yourself you know it's
television or you're doing an interview
or anything you're always going to be up
a little bit you know it's not like when
you're showing at your house having a
conversation but people want to enjoy
the show you know especially when it's a
show that you're being very combative
and you're having really serious
conversations sometimes and you're
having really
um deep arguments and debate you add a
little lightness to it every once in a
while you know do a little do a little
gloating you know pay the Pay The Man
and Diet Mountain Dew and you know and
just enjoy the show
um you obviously go from that to more of
like a real real co-host role with Colin
and I always tell people I've been a
huge Colin Cowherd fan forever because
I'm a radio nerd and I always would just
admire
his ability to go off without anyone to
bounce stuff off of because like you
could listen to him on the radio like
when I was like younger and I'd be like
this guy's it's just him in there just
like just talking and it's like really
entertaining which is really hard as you
know because you've been a part of radio
for so long I think you guys had such a
dope Dynamic on the show as you kind of
being his number two what is it like
because I'm I'm a huge Colin coward fan
what's he like as a guy and just like
what's it like working with him because
you guys had a great run before you went
to speak for yourself and kicked your
own thing off Colin's the best he is I'm
a radio nerd too so you'll appreciate
this he's a huge prepper yeah so he does
a two-hour prep show before the three
hour show right so there's a lot of prep
he's very thorough he wants to make sure
he has the graphics he wants to support
what he's talking about he wants to make
sure that he has the sound he wants to
support what he's talking about he wants
to make sure he has the statistics he's
looked up you know the historical stuff
that goes along with what he's saying he
really talks through all of the topics
so his ability to you know stretch a
subjects the way that you're talking
about and continue to have the
conversation with you the listener but
by himself it's crazy I mean his brain
works differently to be able to do that
anyway but it really also helps that he
preps a lot he doesn't like to waste air
time so sometimes sometimes it depends
on the show obviously but we'll do a
little banter back and forth whatever
about you know being in wine country or
whatever I'm going to Utah but it's
never
too long you know we don't let that
conversation be the conversation we're
having in the segment right he always
brings it back to okay what do we want
to get to here we're going to we're
gonna get to Aaron Rodgers here like we
can we can go a little bit off to make
sure that people know that we're human
beings but we got to talk about what we
planned on talking about he's very very
serious about the show he feels like
it's disrespectful to the audience to
not be prepared to do a show I love it
so that's what that's really what makes
him great and able to do such a big show
because three hours of content is a long
ass show for sure in our business that
is an insanely long show and he does it
as his show so he can do all of that by
himself if he needs to obviously uh for
you because you have your your solo
podcast I haven't done this podcast
but while you were doing uh the coward
show you had your show right
um was the upside for you to leave the
Skip and Shannon show which is the
biggest show on the network to go to
Colin was it because you were able to
have like because you had your own
segment every day were you able to kind
of like you were able to get your [__]
off you know yeah it was like the upside
or like what made you want to make that
move it was partly you know obviously a
different role in a more expanded
speaking role when I first went to Colin
it was still just you know the news
updates he'd bring me in here and there
but like it took a little time for us to
build up the muscle of him being able to
just lean on me when he needed to like
this is trust and chemistry I had done
the show a lot so I already knew the
Beats of the show because I was filling
on her a lot when I was doing Undisputed
so we already knew how to do the show
together but what the show was going to
feel like together just took a little
time and us doing it from home during
the pandemic actually really helped us a
lot because we just had to talk that's
all you had to do that's all we had to
do you have nothing else going on yeah
but for me you know my goal was always
to be in the role that I'm in now and
it was important to me to always keep
growing in the business so I did two
years of Undisputed and I felt like I
had you know mastered that role and
there were you know I'd kind of Hit the
ceiling of how much better I was going
to get at that role and I was ready to
try something different and you know get
into a new challenge in a different type
of show so it was never that like I
didn't want to work with them or
anything like I love Skip and Shannon
and love doing that show it was just
time for me to go to a new role do
something new yeah and similarly that's
that's why I made the jump to to speak
after Colin yo what UPS bootleg cab we
gotta stop the interview to tell you
about our folks at my bookie that's
right so many ways you can gamble with
my bookie right now man of course you
got NBA playoffs Western Conference
Finals Eastern Conference Finals they're
set I love Celtics versus Lakers in the
finals all right you can sign up at
mybookie.ag right now using that promo
code bootleg and get a very generous
first deposit bonus that's right and
they just got the craziest like revamp
of the online casino it's like a Las
Vegas experience if you play cards
Blackjack roulette uh you shoot dice
whatever it is they have like live
dealers handling it for you wherever
you're at you could be at the airport
and be playing [__] roulette on your
phone it's amazing mybookie.ag sign up
with that promo code bootleg right now
you can bet on Sports you could do slots
you could do Blackjack uh craps whatever
you're into mybookie.ag promo code
bootleg for that first deposit bonus and
it is a generous one also gotta give a
shout out to our family at King Palms
shout out to King Palm man if you only
know about King Palms they're our new
sponsor on the bootleg kept podcast and
they got such a great product the best
thing about King Palms is it's all
organic man no tobacco in these wraps
they're straight Leafs and the best
thing uh about them is they got this
product
their flavor terpene tips all right you
stuff them with your with your product
do we got one here oh we do got one here
all right we have one right here we got
one right here all right you stuff this
with your uh premium cannabis from Hardy
in Las Vegas
all right you smoke up pinch that tip
you're gonna get a burst of flavor yeah
this is the energy drink flavor we got
Peach pineapple we got watermelon wave
also don't forget the goddamn
blue grapes you know what I mean and
also this is a tobacco-free wrap it's
totally organic it's literally a leaf
let me show you what I mean
that is just a big ass Leaf guys all
right so what you could do is go to
kingpom.com weeds flying everywhere
kingpop.com promo code bootleg and uh
you can get 50 off of whatever you order
at kingpom.com and don't forget to check
them out because they're everywhere your
local smoke shop your local liquor store
7-Eleven smoke the King Palm all right
it's organic it ain't like all that
other [__] y'all be [__] stuffing
in your lungs man all right shout out to
kingpom kingpom.com promo code bootleg
right now and it's actually promo code
bootleg Kev
half off everything let's get back to
the interview yeah I was gonna say like
for you you're one I mean there's
amazing uh female Personalities in the
Sports World
um you're one of the only women who has
kind of uh
a main role on a debate show at this
point where you're not just like kind of
move like you said moving the segment
you're you know you're you're there as
somebody who gives their opinion every
day for you has it been like
uh you know I do think sports fans for
the most part can be kind of
misogynistic in terms of like the sexism
and [__] like that but you've done a
really good job of like navigating what
I would say like for me when I was in
radio it's like you start off as an
intern then you maybe do weekends and
you've kind of built your way up to
having your own show now how hard is
that being a female and doing sports
like because you are I mean you could
correct me if I'm wrong but are you like
one of the only females who actually in
the opinion space there's very few of us
I don't want to misspeak but maybe one
or two that do uh daily like are on the
show every day as a opinion show that's
not directed towards a specific uh sport
right which you know I would love for
those to be more right
um it's never my goal to be the only one
um it's yeah I mean my career has always
been
um growing and adding to my resume and
the process so like you said I started
as a unpaid intern in Miami and then I
was like a full-time intern and then a
part-time producer and then a full-time
producer and then you're a freelancer on
the side while you're producing and you
know you kind of always have multiple
jobs in this business also right but
yeah I mean I've I've earned my way up
and built my way up but also
I don't know I think
I think it's all in how you not all in
but partly for me it's been
learning from the people and the the
personalities that I worked with
skip is very different than Colin it's
very different than Shannon is very
different than Emmanuel is very
different than shady is different than
last like it was different than Zazzle
in Miami everyone has different things
they bring to the table but you're going
to get criticized no matter what you do
you're going to get criticized more if
you're a woman and you're gonna get
criticized more if you're a black woman
so
for me the misogyny and you know people
even I mean today you can go look on my
social media there's somebody's gonna
say I'm shouldn't be there because I'm a
girl okay Jason's or whatever like yeah
those people don't sign checks so who
gives a [__] they just they don't those
people don't make decisions right they
don't move the needle because for the
most part people are watching and
enjoying good content entertaining
content educated opinionated
content that they resonate with I'm not
saying things that don't make sense
right if you disagree with me it's easy
to say you disagree with me because I'm
a girl but then you're going to run into
somebody else that says that that's a
man and now what are you gonna do now
what are you gonna do so it doesn't
really I've also have a built up a very
thick skin for it I've seen you snap
back at trolls before yeah I say I'm in
retirement now uh mostly because Twitter
is just not as fun as it used to be
right like it just doesn't provide the
same uh same level of entertainment for
me anymore but yeah I mean I don't I'm
happy to you know embarrass somebody or
you know ruin someone's day for sure but
for me it's more about
it's more about letting people know this
isn't this isn't really actually
affecting me and it does certain people
how you approach social media for
everybody in the business is an
important conversation you have to have
with yourself right and to me I'm like
if you wouldn't come to my face and say
this to my face which we know you would
not do that of course you're not going
to do that for sure I can't take you
your criticism seriously in any capacity
if if you if I wouldn't ask for your
advice I don't care about your criticism
right that's some that's some real [__]
I think everybody should have that
that's I mean it's not easy to develop
that though I mean it's there's it's
easier to let [__] get to you too like
even if you don't think like consciously
it's happening subconsciously you think
about that stuff well the subconscious
part is the interesting part because I
think everybody has a different capacity
to deal with feedback the reality is we
know too much about each other we should
not know this much about each other in
society and we all get too much feedback
good and bad so 10 000 people can tell
me I'm right and 10 000 people can tell
me I'm wrong in one day neither one of
them are changing my spirit it's just
it's just not a good habit to have it's
kind of like being an athlete yeah like
you can't you can't get so down because
you lost a game that you can't focus on
the next game right or miss a shot or if
you throw an interception you gotta you
know you got to come back and be a
goldfish yeah so I that's this is how I
approach it but I feel like it's
important for everybody to find their
own way to deal with that kind of
feedback now that you're giving your
opinions on TV every day we've seen a
lot of athletes have very thin skin
right we've seen athletes have public
beefs with skip a thousand times I mean
I mean we could go on and on the list
have you uh had had I'm not going to ask
you to name a name or anything but have
you had anybody
hit you or find out that maybe you had
said something that had them a little
pissed off
I'm sure it's
I feel like sometimes like I feel like a
lot of times people might take some of
the things skip say is like he's like
being mean right I feel like you you
have well delivery delivery can kind of
change delivery matters yeah although I
have been told I don't have the softest
delivery I think and look I mean it may
very well happen I don't really call it
thin skin I don't really believe that
athletes have to
hear about themselves all day long and
not ever say anything to anybody like if
you have something to say to a media
member
say it you know I don't it's not gonna
it's not gonna make me think you're soft
right I get a lot of feedback all day
long but
for the most part people aren't doing
shows about what I do right you know so
it's it's a bit of an imbalance there
when it comes to media and athletes and
also I consider it a massive privilege
to be able to talk about sports and give
my opinion about sports for a living so
you know these these athletes are one
percent of one percenters in what they
do so even if they have a bad night
they're still doing something absolutely
incredible alien like right that very
few people will ever get the opportunity
to do will ever get the opportunity to
fail at so yeah I mean we give strong
opinions but
for me I feel like it's always I try to
keep it all in the back of my head one
not to get too emotional about it
because what is all this really like
we're we're not saving lives here right
and two these are human beings we're
talking about and they do have feelings
and they do put their whole heart and
soul and Blood and Tears and time with
their family and time with their friends
and vacations and like everything into
what they do and they get paid for it
but so what people get paid a lot of a
lot of money to do a lot of things
that's still taxing on their spirit and
still takes time away from other things
that we get to do all the time right so
I just try to keep a human element in
Minds that's not to say someone might
not still get mad
say but maybe you know I don't run into
that too much thankfully uh the one
thing Colin uh does that I always
appreciate is he does his bit where he
talks about where he was wrong yes what
does it take that you've been just
absolutely wrong about recently oh I
mean
all the time I'm wrong with stuff
Acres would do much better in the Nugget
Series in the Nugget series and they did
um I mean listen there's plenty of
people who I'm sure going to put in the
comments what I was super wrong about uh
I don't Focus too much on the things
so maybe that's that but I don't really
take predictions too seriously right so
maybe that's that's why it's not like as
a harsh thing for me I love that bit
that Colin does right and it's funny
because
so many people will come up to me and be
like man I just was calling to say he
was wrong about something I'm like he
does a whole segment every week I was
gonna say he does it every week yeah
literally where I was wrong all the
things that he was super wrong about
yeah
um I don't have a problem saying I'm
wrong though and I don't have a problem
changing my opinion which isn't is not
something that is encouraged to be
practiced in my line of work but I'm not
going to continue saying something when
I have new information true I just don't
view that as something that is one I
don't think the audience really
appreciates that and two I don't think
it ends up working out like if I really
feel strongly about something I won't
back off of it but if you've like if
I've like got new information now what's
your position that you're just like
you're dug in on
what am I dugging like what's your
sports like you know for me I mean I
absolutely can't stand the Baseball Hall
of Fame I mean I just it's it's the most
ridiculous setup it's nonsense it it
infuriates me every time there's a vote
it's it is a
it is a to me just the fact exam and it
is supposed to tell the story of
baseball the fact that Barry Bonds isn't
in the Hall of Fame I just can't take it
serious what am I supposed to say about
that even if you take the season away
where he had 73 home runs he's Barry
Bonds like what are we talking he was a
Hall of Fame he's had like multiple Hall
of Fame careers so that's one thing that
I'm like I don't ever want to hear about
the Baseball Hall of Fame that that
drives me absolutely insane I don't ever
want to hear about baseball
gotta stop the interview real quick to
tell you about our family at Blue chew
baby that's right it's getting hot
outside you know what that means fellas
you're about to go get that dick wet you
know what I'm saying it might as well be
really hard it might as well be as hard
as it could possibly be and with
Bluetooth you will achieve such hardness
all right it's seriously amazing uh and
the best part about Bluetooth is you can
find out if it works don't just take my
word for it they're going to give you a
month's supply for free go to
bluetooth.com use that promo code
bootleg get a month supply for free
bluetooth.com promo code bootleg now
it's the same active ingredient as
Viagra and Cialis minus the awkward
doctor appointment you do not have to go
see some old dude and tell them about
your erectile dysfunction issues in
person because that's a [__] awkward
conversation bruh all you got to do is
go to bluetooth.com right now use the
promo code bootleg they're going to get
you hooked up with a month of supply for
free you just got to pay five dollars in
shipping no awkward doctor's
appointments same active ingredient as
Viagra and Cialis plus they got the
Bluetooth mint it's a chewable it's
great tastes like mint it's also the
same active ingredient as Levitra so
summertime's coming fellas you don't
want to underperform make sure your dick
is rocked up baby all right go to
bluetooth.com use the promo code bootleg
hey man it works what do you want from
me it [__] works everyone should have
a little Bluetooth in case of an
emergency
you might have an emergency you need to
pop a Bluetooth to it it's a chewable
you know what I mean anyway also got a
shout out to our family at Odd Socks
don't forget go to oddstocksofficial.com
promo code bootleg save 20 off man they
got the underwear that they just dropped
uh last year that's amazing so not only
do you get the most comfortable socks in
the world but you can also get the most
comfortable withdrawals in the world all
the crazy licenses they gotta have baked
socks they just announced their Hasbro
collection which is crazy because that
means you're going to get Monopoly socks
Transformer socks Power Ranger socks so
much [__] going with Odd Socks plus they
got The Odd Socks Basics my favorite
this is why I wear every day I wear the
basics because they're the most
comfortable socks I've ever put on my
[__] feet so experience the most
comfortable socks in the world with me
oddsoxofficial.com promo code bootleg
save 20 off shout out to Odd Socks let's
get back to the interview
um I am a Michael Jordan Zealot so so
you're it'll be very very difficult to
ever move me off of the position that
Michael is the greatest baseball
basketball player can you at least agree
that the only right answer to who's the
goat is him or LeBron
yes okay but I will also respect someone
who
puts Kareem in there Kareem would be the
only other one like if you're like if
you're like 85 and you're like but you
didn't see Kareem's son I think it's
I mean the go conversation we've kind of
you know done
ad nauseam and I absolutely respect
LeBron James and I think it's yeah it's
such a gift that we have been able to I
think we've taken for Advantage
sometimes I don't take him for granted
I'll tell you why I don't take him for
granted one because I'm a Heat fan so
like thank you LeBron yeah but I was
really you know it's kind of my feelings
about the Clevelands era after the heat
but once he came to the Lakers I was
like
I'm gonna enjoy this right like I'm not
going to you're living in L.A better
watch yeah yeah like and also he did
what he wanted to do and I'm not like I
got championships in Miami because of it
and had it really started my career in
Miami right in a great way because he
decided to come to the heat but I'm not
going to to be that person that was like
man
I got an opportunity to watch Michael
Jordan but I just hated him so much I
just barely came to that with Steph
because I like hate I like hate to I
hate the Warriors really I just because
I'm a die hard I got a LeBron toy right
there I'm a die-hard Suns fan but this
the dark years as you know the dark
years have been dark recently yeah so
since the Suns have been absolutely
cheeks I've always just rooted for
whatever team LeBron was on so I'm
[__] sure I'm a Heat fan Cavaliers
fan hate the Lakers but rooted for the
Lakers in the bubble year you know but
uh I just the the LeBron Steph battles
that's fair I just saw so many fair
weather Warrior fans at the time I lived
in Florida I lived in Tampa and uh there
was all of a sudden in the middle of the
State of Florida there's all these
Warrior fans well people like like to
people like to root for things that are
fun yeah you know if you're gonna if
you're gonna get in on the NBA like it's
not a bad one he just gets so much hate
and I'm like he's such a good guy he's
never done a weirdo I think LeBron is
I think he is the greatest superstar
that we have ever seen in the history of
sports for sure and possibly like ever
in the country when you think about the
fact that he was in high school high
school was famous in high school on
Sports Illustrated
coming from that to now being how old is
he now 40 39 39 yeah 39 years old played
for 21 years in the NBA
has zero blemishes personally he's yeah
what's his biggest controversy that he
made a big announcement that he was
going to play for a better organization
after the organization that had him for
seven years couldn't put another player
around him exactly what's his oh and by
the way raise
millions of dollars for charity and
doing it that's crazy what's his big
controversy that he won't speak about
China
right that's it that's all I mean people
people make up [__] like I mean give me
a break this guy's impeccable he's
elevated everyone around him he has
raised a family like has an unbelievable
family life has represented the NBA for
20 years and been the face and the
criticism like it's
it's just take a step back it's
remarkable it's never been done you can
look at any Superstar we've ever had in
sports and music and entertainment and
movies you're just gonna fall apart at
some point it's just human nature yeah
like the fact that he hasn't with all
the scrutiny and hate that he constantly
gets couldn't be me couldn't be me
couldn't be me either uh okay so
obviously every day speak is on it's
just speak now right yes just speak
because it will speak for yourself yes
now it's not just speak speak Rebrand
new logo
it's 4 30 p.m Eastern so 1 30 p.m 1 30
p.m West Coast 4 30 p.m Eastern you know
we do everything for the for the east
coast and yeah what is up with that it's
so fresh it's East Coast
but accepted because I was the East
Coast girl for a long time but you must
be let's be honest you had no idea the
heat we're gonna make it as an 8C to the
finals did you I did not I did not I'll
be honest I was always Tyler hero went
down holding on to faith because I I
blindly have faith in Pat Riley and Eric
spaulstra although I will say this
the Milwaukee series after the Milwaukee
series I know like I didn't think that
they would get through Milwaukee because
it's Giannis and Milwaukee and the after
that series went the way that it did
then I knew really yes you thought they
would they would get the Celtics well
think about it and listen I've done this
this bit like 15 times this week but
you said you can't stand the Warriors
right don't worry so much since 2010
yeah
the Warriors have I think a hundred and
eight
playoff wins I'm sure some of them will
correct me but I think 108 playoff wins
the Heat have 106. oh no it's crazy
suppose the heat up into six finals the
Warriors have been to six finals it's
great
it's great we don't think of it
yeah like they they've they've been to
the finals two of the last four years
yeah
air exposure is the goat man like it was
the Heat and he's never one coach of the
year the Heat Bucks Celtics Heats so the
Heat have been in the finals in the last
four years more than any other team in
the east
they were in the Eastern Conference
Finals against the Celtics last year in
a game seven and two years ago beat them
in a game six so they've met the Celtics
in the Eastern Conference Finals three
of the last four years and beat them in
two of them true it's just it's just
it's a heat bias and I'll tell you what
it is it's it's that man people are
still mad that LeBron went to the heat
they are still mad about it they might
be they didn't hate the heat before that
I'm telling you think about it Dwyane
Wade Shaq Pat Riley Zoe like it's it's
Miami what's not the love about it
there's nothing to hate about it they
didn't get hate until LeBron came there
and no one has gone over it and now
because it's it's not the way that
people want the team to look
you know it's Jimmy and everyone's like
well like Jimmy's not a regular season
Superstar he's not an Empire he's
definitely like a very unique player and
and the way he comes alive I mean look
he's been oh I think he's five time all
NBA's in his career you know six-time
All-Star I mean he's a great player but
he's not a player that people he's not
flash he's not he's not flashing he's
not someone that
he got to be like oh yeah he's
doesn't look the way people wanted to
look it but I'm just telling you there's
all these random dudes that they they
got from like other teams like Caleb
Martin and the Gabe Vincent guys
the heat with Pat Riley and Eric
Spoelstra have had a dynasty
for since 2010 yeah I mean yeah they got
the only difference is
Katie had that time with the Warriors oh
trust me I know and listen I've had to
come to the terms of I hung out with
Kevin Durant during the pandemic once at
his house and he was the nicest guy ever
oh yeah he's great and I was like damn I
gotta go on my Twitter account delete
all these tweets bruh people you think
people get mad at LeBron people get so
mad at Katie I don't understand and then
he now he's on my sons so now I'm like
[__] I bought me a pair of KDs I love
Kevin Duran I will always root for Kevin
Durant he is one of my favorite players
to watch I loved him until he went to
the Warriors and now I love him again
I mean I don't I had no problem with
that I think I'm also a bit desensitized
to it because I thought it was so funny
how people reacted to LeBron going to
the heat yeah so so you were like this
is nothing this is well it also with
Kevin Durant and similar to LeBron
because it was the same thing they
didn't have a championship with KD I
think people have Rewritten The
Narrative a little bit because of the
way that this the Thunder lost to the
Warriors right because they were up 3-1
people act like Katie just
took the easy way out right
also he was with the Thunder for like
eight years also he took them to a
finals
knew something about playing with Russ I
think we all have been in the loop about
recently I mean you know maybe that was
not the worst thing to leave for us
because Russ doesn't seem like the
easiest guy and they and they
prioritized Russ over Katie they did so
what are you actually mad about your mag
that he went to a great team was he
supposed to go to like a bad team right
I don't believe in I don't believe in
um
like suffer hustling like he doesn't
need he already did his time he did
seven or eight years in Oklahoma in
Oklahoma City one MVP there went to the
finals there and decided to move on why
are you mad that he went to a great team
and now who by the way was so well run
Bob Meyer is now leaving who knows it's
gonna happen was so well run that they
had Klay Thompson
Steph Curry and Draymond Green and could
fit Kevin Durant on that team sorry your
team's not well run I gotta ask you one
last thing because I know you got to go
uh give me your take on my Phoenix Suns
so I well I just made an impassioned
speech for governor yet so I'll stay
with that I love Booker two I think
I think the coaching is going to be
important yeah I think you're seeing I
was hoping we were going to get Nick
nurse but he went to Philly yeah I think
I think the coaching hire is going to be
important it's not Doc Rivers please the
role players are also going to be very
important yeah because you you did give
up some depth and you know you give up
whatever you need to give up to get
Kevin Durant but
I think they're gonna look a lot
different next year I think no more
Aiden please I give them a lot of Grace
that probably everybody else doesn't
give them because they looked so good as
soon as Katie got there but they didn't
play a lot together that's how I tell
everybody so during the regular season
they played eight games then remember he
got hurt right and so I'm like guys like
we barely are seeing these guys figure
this out and also like I love Monty
Williams because he's changed the
culture of the Suns but yeah just like
zero like real offense was being ran it
literally was like
all right book it's your turn all right
Katie it's your turn
yeah but that doesn't surprise me
because they didn't have enough they
didn't have that's what I mean they
didn't have enough time so I think
they're going to look very different
next year definitely they need some
depth right but once they're in you know
they're rolling together they're going
to be a much harder out I mean they
still went six with the Nuggets who are
now in the finals so it's not like it's
you know you need to hang your head too
much right I know people think Kevin
Durant should win a championship every
year and they were favored and look I I
thought they would go further as well
but I think they're going to look very
different next year it's not over well
I'm a huge Suns fan hopefully we figure
it out
hopefully your heat win the finals thank
you I I also don't like Denver I like
yolkit she's he's just he's just too
good it's like frustratingly good like
when you're because I'm a Suns fan
watching that [__] guy who
looks just so out of shape he's not out
of shape I know but he just looks he
looks like someone in my friend group
you know they're like I should you be
playing basketball like I could like
reverse and he's just so good it's just
it's just crazy it's just he is he's
really he's an he is an irritatingly
good player he's so irritatingly good
but he's so good he's the next time he's
up for an MVP there's not going to be as
much pushback as there was this time I
know and it's like I really wanted
embiid to win this year me too I did
because I feel like yo he deserves one
you know but damn if
yogic proved everybody who voted for him
being wrong I mean
that and then I was like what also yoga
shouldn't win three in a row because he
hasn't done anything in the postseason
yet no I'm like all right well not not
y'all calling me a hypocrite but I don't
like to play that game though too much
listen it was a regular season award and
bled league and scoring jokic took the
last one he absolutely deserved it I
mean he he deserved it it's he's playing
with James Harden it's not the easiest
thing maybe we should make a postseason
MVP I agree I'm surprised they haven't
done that yet well I'm just making a
program it's like the finals MVP but
like the finals MVP kit is so specific
to that series we're just making up
trophies at this point like the fact
There's a western conference in Eastern
Conference like and I'm like this is
stupid anyway Joy Taylor uh you can
watch her on TV every single day
1 30 PM PST 4 30 p.m EST yes on FS1
speak on speed I'll go watch it on
YouTube too that's where I watch it I
watch it on YouTube thank you for having
me of course hey we gotta wrap up an
interview brought to you by hardean Las
Vegas appreciate y'all watching hey
don't forget when you go to Vegas you
got to go to Hardee man it's the
craziest dispensary you'll ever walk
into it smells like [__] heaven in
there all right get in that Uber when
you hit Sin City tell them take me to
hardine they're gonna take you you're
gonna get a wild selection of the just
top top of the line cannabis the best
selection you'll go uh be able to see in
the US Plus on top of that they got the
crazy gear they got the clothes they got
the bikinis they got a wonderful
selection of Bud tenders that are very
good at their job man they'll take care
of you tell them that bootleg have sent
you the bud tenders are Harding don't
know what that means they're gonna get
you hooked up right all right go follow
them online Harding underscore Las Vegas
or just go check out their website too
man hardinglasvegas.com and when you're
in Vegas pull up to Jardin or you're
playing yourself for real